bonjour je m'appelle Grace Allen et
figure-toi que je suis ta mère je te
saurais gré de me rappeler dans les plus
brefs délais enfin bref
on embarque bientôt pour la Colombie et
Kevin et moi on compte sur toi pour
venir nous chercher lundi à l'aéroport
et pas de soirée à la maison à notre
absence bien reçu pas de fun
radio
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le portable de graisse Allen laissez-moi
un message maman
vous êtes où
[Musique]
ici la jean-parc j'ai vraiment besoin de
vous c'est ma mère elle a disparu vous
pouvez faire quelque chose nous ne
sommes pas habilités
[Musique]
et je peux pas venir sur place j'ai
besoin que vous alliez dans cet hôtel
demander à voir leur vidéo de
surveillance
fouille dans les emails de Kevin il y a
une femme qui l'appelle Darren vous
attendiez quoi pour me dire que ma mère
sortait avec un escroc
j'aimerais vous parler d'un nouvel
élément de l'enquête notre mère a
peut-être déjà changé d'identité
une affaire extrêmement étrange de mine
d'actualité pourquoi elle m'a caché un
truc pareil la police
fait caca quand même de quoi se poser
des questions tout le monde peut
commettre des erreurs même tes parents
il y a beaucoup de choses dont
j'aimerais te parler